It was way past my bedtime,
and even though take out did sound enticing,
I knew it wouldn't hit the same as a home cooked comfort meal.
So today we made some bangers and mash,
but without the mash. Instead we did roast potatoes.
I still had a few potatoes left that our friends brought from Idaho,
so I cut those up, boiled them,
and shook them
before transferring them over onto a baking sheet with hot duck fat.
Season my potatoes before popping them in the oven for 45 minutes.
In the meantime,
I got started on my red wine gravy by slicing up some red onions
and sauteing them in a pot with some butter.
Once they softened and got some color,
I sprinkled in some flour
before pouring in some of my red wine beef stock
and then letting that simmer on the stove until it thickened up,
which was about 30 minutes.
In the meantime, I got started on prepping my lemon garlic broccolini.
Took some of the stems off and thinly sliced my garlic
before sauteing all of that in some olive oil, salt,
pepper, and a squeeze of lemon.
I also had some of these really good German sausages in the fridge,
so I let those brown and then it was time to plate.
Put my duck fat roasted potatoes down some broccoli knee my sausages,
and then spooned over my red wine gravy.
This is one of my comfort meals and it's absolutely Divine